time to check back in with Rocky she is
showing us how to have an onalicious big
game party at Island Sushi Grill what's
the catering game plan there Rocky
culturally they're asking what's on the
catering game day plan and this is how
it goes okay let's break it down
halftime poke platter right here first
down sushi roll platter second down
Sushi more sushi rolls third down we've
got Sashimi final touchdown we're going
back to sushi rolls because that's what
you guys are all about so what are we
making coach
Ahi fever I fever is this one of your
most popular ones yep one of our popular
ones okay so as I attempt this okay I
want to ask you why is this a healthier
option for the big game on Sunday
um Sushi you know just fresh vegetables
fresh fish
um it's not fried there's no additives
to it it's just fresh ingredients oh
shoot coach oh spicy tuna right right
right that's why you're here that's why
you're here okay it's fresh ingredients
it's healthier options but they don't
have to ditch the fried foods no no but
they should balance it out yeah a little
balance just a little bit Alice
okay how am I doing how much you're
doing good okay well okay tell everybody
this is the onalicious
big game Sunday what is the onalicious
lifestyle all about I hear singing I
hear music it's about having fun and
enjoying delicious food
we like that we love that in Las Vegas
now now as I roll this here talk about
your most popular roles on the menu and
that people can order on these platters
one of our specials is uh the island
special it's a spicy crab mix with a
spicy tuna up top and drizzled with
spicy mayo and sweet soy sauce
I love that this is tuna right yes
that's tuna and what you're making now
is our Ahi fever and that's one of our
popular roles as well
boom
yeah that is what you can get on a
platter like this for the big game tell
everybody how they can order their
platters I'm thinking of this in advance
give us a call at
702-221-1600 place your order place your
reservations or you can give us a
contact on our website okay islandsushi
and grill.com easy as that you guys this
feeds about 20 to 25 people so they have
the whole family everybody covered and
they've got the drinks to go along with
it okay I'll send it back to you